I wanna talk about this kind of
gendered cycle of people pleasing in regards to Taylor Swift
I don't know what it's called
I've just been thinking about it
it's just occurred to me and I've realised something
I'm Doctor Zoe
I have a PhD in digital feminist activism
and I like to make accessible
content for people to further their feminist identities
so Taylor Swift has made everyone feel very uncomfortable and ill at ease
I think we all knew she was just getting so high
and almost just like half wondering
she'll fall really far
and half wondering if she's just untouchable at this point
she's a billionaire
so in many way
she is untouchable
but in terms of her PR status
as we know from Elon Elon Musk
she's not untouchable
she's actually got just way more to lose
and I guess a lot of people are commenting on whether it was actually
appropriate for her to announce a whole new album at the Grammys
um not to mention a couple of little social faux pas around Lana Del Rey
dragging her up on stage
the snob of Selena
um Celine Dion
the Queen and it got me thinking okay
because I've been thinking a lot about people pleasing and women
and I just thought like
I'm not that much of a people pleaser
and I think that that's really great
cause I'm kind of like just no
that's not gonna hold me back
I don't really care that much
but then I was like
reflecting lately that actually
I kind of am a people pleaser
just in the way that women just are because of the way that we're socialised
and that it can play out in different ways
and we know that Taylor Swift is a self identified people pleaser
if you've watched Miss Americana
always wanted to be the good girl
and then it's just never enough for people
and I've been thinking about the rap race and the kind of treadmill of success
and you get stuck in this cycle
and I think that that's what happened here with our friend Miss Swift
and take this with a grain of salt
because she's a billionaire
she's a white woman
and she's Taylor Swift
so this is you know
an ill formed thought
but basically
women tend to not feel entitled to our success
we've been born into worlds that are vastly unequal
and we're positioned as a second sex
as Simone de Beauvoir says
um we are made to feel like our destiny is tied to
a lot of time our biology
like our reproductive potential
um and we know that we end up in domestic servitude
I forgot one
but basically
men do feel entitled
and women tend to
not have that sense of entitlement over everything and everyone
and therefore
when we do achieve success
we feel like we have to work twice as hard to earn it
to earn the same recognition of success
and that when we get it
we have to keep showing people that we still deserve it
by continuing to work
not just twice as hard
but I feel like it multiplies
every time you achieve more status and more success
so you're never like
getting to an arrival point and going cool
I achieved it
I'm posting now
it's like you get to that point
you set that goal
you hit that milestone girl
and then you're like cool
now I have to just
like feel guilty
do I deserve it
did I work hard enough
you know do I have to keep proving to everyone that I do deserve this
the thing that I worked for
because now I've got it
I don't quite believe that I
did deserve it and I don't
I feel kind of like an imposter
and now I just have to like
work a million times harder
to keep showing everyone
that I do deserve it
and then I achieve the next milestone
and then I have to
keep doing that again
so I'm exhausted
and I never feel like it's enough
and I think that's what happened
with Taylor Swift
do I think it explains everything
no like it is
it's just one
angle and one take
but I feel like
she has achieved like
this just ridiculous level of
like success
like it's on
undoubtable like it's
whether or not you like it
it's just not deniable um
and it's almost like
how does one person
like come to terms
with that within
within themselves
and Taylor Swift
we know like
she's a perfectionist
we know she's always like
I want that next thing I want that
she never stops you know
and it's like
but when she gets it
she probably feels this immense pressure
to prove to everyone that she
deserves it is the best
is the best songwriter
is the hardest worker
to keep justifying
the more and more success she get
so that's why I feel like she announced her album
apart from like
obviously taking advantage of the sales
it was of quite a
like culturally blind
thing to do in a lot of ways
but I feel like
she felt like she needed to
because in order to accept
her record breaking Grammy
her fourth um
the only person to get four
um album of the year
in order to accept is
like huge thing
beating like
Stevie Wonder
and everyone else in that category
she had to then show
that she is still
the best and the most deserving
by using that opportunity
um well she used the earlier Grammy opportunity
but still using that opportunity on that night
to announce yet another album
when everyone's like
you just won Grammys for the
that album you'd seem to have just released
and now you're
you know doing another one
and you've surprised us all
because we were just expecting a re recording
and now you've done this
and it's like yes
she has to keep going
like that next
step and like
my question is
when does that end
and how does that end
and where does that go
um and have you ever felt like that
have you ever felt like
the success that you have achieved
um you then have to
like justify
retrospectively
why you've achieved it
by continuing
to go harder than you did last time
and do you ever feel like you're on that treadmill
and you don't know
when it ends
and how to get off
lastly I'll just say
it is gendered
absolutely we know that rates of imposter syndrome
and people pleasing
are higher in women
in gender diverse people
in LGBTQ community in
uh for people of colour
for people who aren't basically like
straight white men
we know that they
don't get that feeling of
entitlement over just like
claiming everything that they want in the world
and then when they get it
they must also feel
and we must also feel
um a sense of guilt
or a sense of why me
or a sense of
yeah imposter
imposter syndrome around
the success that we do
manage to achieve
and so that is why it is
it is gendered um
intrinsically
as an issue and yeah
I would love to know
your thoughts on that